in terms of good acting careers what do
you do to drum up work for yourselves
what's your day like good question such
a thing and everything I mean nowadays
with facebook and you know it's like
you're trolling first time showing on
and who's doing what and you know it's
still the same for me at least to just
say yes to every single last thing
unless it's just you can sniff out
something that looks like a dead end I
just try to meet people that I respect
and if I like their work and I like them
as people I want to be their friends and
then when you become friends with
somebody you want to work together you
want to create things together this is a
lot of ground up things where you keep
throwing stuff at the wall and ninety
percent of it doesn't happen but the ten
percent that does happen it's usually
working with really smart talented
people that you love and that's very
much like what this movie is you know
we're a family and create fun stuff and
then you get to hang out with each other
for the following year traveling around
with it yeah I would say a big part of
it especially like in the independent
film scene is like networking you know
and just enlarging your circle as time
goes on with your work and I think
personal relationships like Jenna says
is a
really big part of it especially I think
for like the independent film scene
because it's a small it's a small world
yeah and speed working it so pushy too
he's always like Jen let's work together
and I'm like yeah back off dude just
real quick before we wrap up what's your
take on social media you mentioned
Facebook sort of trolling it looking for
opportunities in some sense but a lot of
people are sort of turned off by having
to spend so much time there promoting
themselves so what's your take about
Twitter and Facebook and Google+ it can
become a chore in itself yeah navigate
all that is this a little bit of a
part-time job but it's so useful and you
get to connect and share what you're
doing with your friends and your
acquaintances and colleagues and you
also get to see what they're doing and
you get to support each other and it
feels really great to be able to go to
see their movies and they come see your
movies and it creates this really
supportive circle keeping each other
inspired is a big thing to just during
the down times in between roles and and
you know but there's a fine line wasting
your time too and I'm actually being in
a you know creative environment
physically with people than just you
know wasting time on the computer and
interestingly it should be said for a
small film like this social media really
is important and can't play a crucial
role and in fact we're working with like
tug for example to try to get more
screenings in cities where the film as
of now is not playing so people can
request a screaming in their hometown
and if enough people sign up to go to
the screening they'll bring it to really
any theater in the United States it's a
new thing that they just launched in
march but it's really cool and they're
working with us to do that to bring it
more widespread around the country
we mentioned down times as creative
people we all kind of go through this
bipolar wide what are the movies that
you watch to take you to a happy place
and pge are rated on it I like
depressing movies that make me cry yeah
yeah not even depressing I like movies
that make me feel something really
powerful and strongly and I don't go as
much for um you know fun comedies
although those are great and I enjoy
them if it is not what I tend to
gravitate towards i would say specific
movies One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
and The Shining well Fisher uplifting
mm-hmm may I have hey get me fired up
and planes trains and automobiles let's
say for me it's a wonderful life always
makes me cry but at the same time it
find it very inspiring and Jimmy Jimmy
Stewart is one of my favorite actors so
he's my man
you